what we all see in driving around trash
on the roads a resident contacted 8 news
now tired of the debris filling the
streets in the Northwest part of town
this story a result of the calling into
our eight news now phone bank where you
took your community concerns and we are
addressing them Mary Jane bellies alive
now near the 95 and Rancho Drive with
more Mary Jane
well Kirsten with trash and debris
starting to pile up around this area and
eight news now viewer wants to know who
cleans it up and how the community can
help
Michael Kaiser enjoys coming to Lorenzi
Park several times a week I play here at
lorenzie Park I love playing here it's
like a second home but says the trash is
becoming hard to avoid on the side of
the street I play senior softball and
and it irks me that there's garbage
sitting two feet away from a trash
receptacle and I pick it up and I throw
it away Kaiser who lives near Rancho and
Alta says it's becoming an eyesore it's
a horrible thing Mary Chain because I
drive down Rancho and I see garbage
piled up in the drainage systems that
they have on Rancho by the 95 granted a
lot of it is the homeless but there are
people who just don't care cleanup on
the freeways is a joint effort between n
dot maintenance Crews and a contractor
two n dot Crews sweep and clean
overnight those Crews frequently respond
to emergency repairs and other
maintenance issues ndot is facing
Staffing challenges with those Crews and
it's not just Rancho in the 95. you can
see trash sprawled on nearby streets
like Vegas Drive and Washington Avenue
the city of Las Vegas oversees general
maintenance on roughly 1 250 miles of
roads in the valley including street
sweeping storm drain flood control and
Sewer maintenance while the city and
ndot are doing their part to clean what
they can Kaiser says it's up to us to
help them I would like to see some task
force or a litter task force let's just
watch each other you see something on
the ground near your house pick it up
bring it home throw it away
you can request a cleanup service
through the city's website and there are
cleanup volunteer groups and
organizations available to join
reporting live near the 95 in Rancho
Mary Jane beliesza 8 News Now